hi I'm Erik Bosse and as we watch the
vendors end game one line stands out
from Doctor Strange as particularly
cryptic despite everything this
secretive sorcerer supreme says coming
out like a freakin riddle when stark
asks strange in the final battle if this
version of events was the one victorious
future that he foresaw an infinity war
strange responds if I tell you what
happens it won't happen yeah in a moment
I think we all interpreted the line as
strange referring to that classic
paradox of determinism versus
time-travel that knowing future events
ahead of time could risk those events
not unfolding properly but many of us
nerds have questioned dr. Strange's
intentions over the months because the
dude is just too smart and he's seen too
much and he's choosing his words too
goddamned carefully for us to take
everything he says at face value but
when dr. strange looked ahead at 14
million different future outcomes how
exactly did he do that for the timelines
in which he died like remember in the
Doctor Strange film the ancient one told
strange I spent so many years peering
through time looking at this exact
moment but I can't see past it never
further the ancient one could look ahead
at her life timeline but not beyond her
death so how could strange look beyond
his death was he lying to Stark when he
said that he looked ahead at these
futures and there was one in which they
won why well it is worth keeping in mind
that the ancient one also told strange
in that scene that when she tried to
look ahead at his future that she never
saw it only its possibilities in an end
game she told hold that strange was
destined to be the best of them the most
powerful sorcerer supreme implying that
strange could use the time stone in ways
that she never knew how to also strange
may not have been able to see his own
timeline beyond his death but presumably
his timeline fast forward would have hit
a foul not bound section and then picked
back up after Hulk snapped them all back
five years later also despite not being
able to perceive his own timeline after
his death he could still theoretically
perceive everyone else's timelines the
surviving Avengers in their future time
heist mission recently a Reddit user
named Robin Hood o 509 posted a
fascinating reexamination of strangest
scenes and dialogue Anthony Dworkin an
endgame from his point of view and all
the different visions strange could have
seen like endgame Thanos's even more
horrific plan to use the stones to
reduce the
universe two atoms and to start over and
applying all of this to Y strange said
what he said to start and that brings up
the question what if dr. strange
actually saw several possibilities in
which the Avengers could win against
Thanos but he specifically lied to start
by telling him that there was only one
victorious path forward
why would strange do that before he
continued thank you to manscape for
sponsoring this episode
if only Doctor Strange could look ahead
to the future to tell us which of the
strokes of our downstairs grooming will
lead to us getting gored like Tony Stark
was but fellas I'm here to tell you you
no longer have to worry about trimming
that body hair because manscaped has you
covered manscape calm is the only men's
Brant dedicated to below the waist
grooming and hygiene with tools created
by a team of aerospace engineers
featured on shark tank
yeah these geniuses are the sorcerer
Supremes of pube trimmers join me in
this realization that you shouldn't use
the same razor to trim your beard as you
do to trim other places and check out
this baby the lawnmower 2.0 it's a
waterproof trimmer with a powerful 6000
RPM motor it comes with a replaceable
ceramic blade head with skin-safe
technology meaning you won't get nicked
or snagged we're feeling like star-lord
post Gamora why is Gamora always not
checking manscape comelet's to get a
replacement blade delivered every three
months to ensure the trimmer stays
hygienic and their perfect package 2.0
manscaping kit also comes with a cropped
preserver moisturizing deodorant a crop
revive or spray and the crop cleanser
shower gel they also got Cologne and the
magic mat disposable shaving mats with
comics to read now you've got some
reading material as you get creative and
shave dr. Strange's weird go-to into
your nuts so guys get manscaping the
shot it's summertime freshen up that
swimsuit area with these travel friendly
tsa approved products it's risk free
30-day money-back guarantee and here's a
free gift for New York star subscribers
this shed travel bag get 20% off plus
free shipping Plus this free gift with
the code rock stars 20 at manscaped comm
ok back to Doctor Strange of the
possibility that he's a big stick a liar
by telling Tony Stark if I tell you what
happens it won't happen Doctor Strange
could have been insinuating that he was
well aware of Starks greatest flaw his
ego I'm the best
and Avengers age of Ultron Stark
similarly received a vision of the
future a horrific outcome probably a lot
like the millions of game overs that
strange for saw Starks response to this
vision this too clever engineered
tinkered and tinkered until he almost
blew up the world Ultron is what
happened had struck ton nothing in
response to seeing this possible future
we wouldn't have had Ultron and instead
of vision we would have had a mind stone
that would've been a lot easier to
destroy the conflicts of the first two
Avengers films let's start with an
unbelievable hero complex and an ego
that dr. strange very quickly clashed
with an infinity war so it's very likely
that strange knew that if in that moment
an end game he told Stark okay yes Tony
Stark it's time for you to make the gyro
play and snap baños away it scorch
yourself he would have risked Stark
overthinking it improvising off that
plan and possibly spurn it up leading to
it not happening in and Strange's
various looks into the future perhaps
the one constant of these successful
futures was that Stark thanks there was
only one way to win and for Stark to
only learn of his sacrificial role at
the very last second because think about
it for every other part of that plan
Stark needed to be very much alive
decoding time-travel helping recall
where and when all the stones were in
history and how to get them as well as
backup options like the camp Lehi
side-trip all until by holding up one
trembling finger and the final battle
strange signal to Stark okay now you
know this is it really who knows how
many win options Doctor Strange could
have foreseen it could have been one it
could have been a hundred or could have
been zero but since the Avengers did win
and Doctor Strange did foresee some of
this victory we have to assume that part
of his plan was to tell Stark that only
one path led to victory and by telling
Stark one nothing further
strange less stark with just enough hope
to keep the man tinkering but not let
Starks crippling ego take over and
isolate him from the other Avengers who
were also crucial to this victory by
choosing his words super carefully
Doctor Strange allowed Tony Stark and
the Avengers to win and lose and the way
that they always should together do you
think Doctor Strange lied to Stark
comment down below with your thoughts
and follow me on Instagram and on
Twitter
a boss it subscribed to new rock stars
to break down some everything Marvel
thank you for joining me and if strange
was manipulating Stark with his words
there let's hope he didn't just
manipulate things to lead start to a
death that strange force saw millions of
times
I mean strange doesn't hate Stark that
much does he
[Music]